A lot of people out there think that Andy Richter
is a nice, easy-going guy.
And I wanna tell you he really is.
Yeah, I'd like to think so.
[Conan] Yeah, you are.
But I just want to point out,
there's another layer of Andy.
A layer where he really wants people to think he's a guy
who cares passionately about American culture.
I care that people think I care.
[Conan] Yes.
(audience laughing and clapping)
That's a big thing for Andy.
Yeah.
So Andy wanted to take a moment to address some of the
things that everyone is talking about.
Are you ready Andy?
I'm ready Conan.
(piano music)
♪ Andy Richter pretends to care deeply about stuff ♪
♪ He doesn't give a shit about ♪
(audience laughing)
They say Khloe Kardashian's new baby girl has her own
Instagram with 144,000 followers.
You go baby True.
(audience laughing)
That Avengers movie made so much money this weekend.
Good for Marvel and Disney.
(audience laughing)
The Mets are off to their best start in franchise history.
Woot, woot.
(audience laughing)
I can't get enough of people posting their old headshots
online.
(audience laughing)
That new Cobra Kai series with Ralph Macchio
may just get me to try YouTube Red.
It might.
(audience laughing)
Keep tweeting your truth Kanye.
(audience laughing and clapping)
But most of all, Conan has his annual check up tomorrow,
and I hope the doctor tells him he's gonna live
a really long time.
(audience cheering and clapping)
(piano music)
♪ Andy Richter pretends to care deeply about stuff ♪
♪ He doesn't give a shit about ♪
Back to you Conan.
(audience cheering and clapping)